me encuentro el memorial del genocidio
armenio de yereván donde en este momento
se están realizando los actos oficiales
del aniversario 106 de las masacres
perpetradas por el estado turco en ese
momento el imperio otomano contra el
pueblo armenio a raíz de la cual más de
un millón y medio de armenios fueron
masacrados ayer por la noche se realizó
la marcha de las antorchas hasta este
memorial y ahora se reciben las visitas
oficiales de las autoridades de armenia
a las cuales también se sumó más de una
decena de delegaciones de diferentes
partes del mundo casi 30 países
reconocieron oficialmente el genocidio
armenio siguiendo los pasos de uruguay
en 1965 y luego también lo hizo francia
en el 2001 muchas concepciones han
cambiado en la sociedad armenia a raíz
de la última guerra de nagorno garapa y
por supuesto han renovado los reclamos
del pueblo armenio ya no se trata
solamente de lo que ocurrió a
seiscientos seis años sino también de lo
que el pueblo armenio
vivió hace tan solo algunos meses cuando
ser vayan con el apoyo explícito de
turquía atacó el territorio de nagorno
gana paz desencadenando una guerra a
gran escala en la cual la población
civil también fue foco de ataque